the sigh of relief at the financial
markets was a big one central banks
around the world are holding strong and
pumping more money into the economy but
what does that say about the state of
the global economy I'd like to welcome
heiko Peters of Deutsche Bank research
the DX is taking the temperature if you
will of the global economy what kind of
summer are we facing at the moment we
saw a marked improvement of the day
weeks in July and that point store a
growth rate of the world economy of
around three and a half percent
especially the sentiment indicator in
the United States and proved
surprisingly to the upside in June the
weakening Chinese economy dampened the
mood what kind of signals coming
currently from the second on the world's
second largest economy the PM is
improved slightly and at the moment
there are at the level of slightly above
50 slightly above the expansionary level
and what we see if at the moment is that
china is moving sideways so no relief
not at the moment but we we expect the
Chinese economy to recovery and the
course of the year the major central
bank's holding on to their policy of low
interest rates is this the way to go at
the moment we still have a relatively
high uncertainty on the development of
the world economy and the next quarter's
and so the kind the economy still
neither the Variax very loose monetary
policy and what is what is crucial and
with their upcoming recovery is that the
central bank's find the correct point of
the right right time to exit the
expansionary policy stingettes signals
from europe on the other hand are quite
positive at the moment we see the
Purchasing Manager index for the private
sector it shows growth for the first
time in one and a half
years have we overcome the worst in the
euro crisis and the eurozone we see
indeed some very good news in recent
months that PM eyes are slightly about
50 and so the count the eurozone economy
should and pick up with moderate growth
rates and the second and the second half
of the year many things mr. Peters we
will talk more about this topic later on
is the euro crisis just taking a break
for summer or are we seeing signs of
real recovery you can find out more
about that at DW de / made in Germany